تحديدا في دير البلح ومستشفى شهداء الاقصى
حيث
انت الاوضاع هي مزيد من القصف الاسرائيلي
المتواصل منذ عده ايام على المناطق
الشرقيه لدير البلح وايضا شرق خانيونس كما
هو في شرق رفح كذلك هذه المناطق تتعرض الى
قصف عنيف من المدفعيه الاسرائيليه ربما في
وسط القطاع على الاقل انخفضت حده الغارات
الاسرائيليه لم نعد نستمع الى اصوات غارات
اسرائيليه عنيفه كما حدث في صباح هذا
اليوم عندما نفذت الطائرات الحربيه
الاسرائيليه سلسله من الغارات على هذه
المناطق وسط القطاع لكن الان انخفضت حده
هذه الغارات الجويه بينما يتكثف حده القصف
المدفعي الاسرائيلي لا سيما على المناطق
الشماليه لوسط القطاع شمال مخيم النصيرات
هذه المناطق منطقه المغرا منطقه مدينه
الزهراء منطقه المفتي شمال مخيم النصيرات
تتعرض الى قصف عنيف من المدفعيه
الاسرائيليه كذلك منطقه شرق مخيم البريج
تتعرض هي الاخرى الى قصف من المدفعيه
الاسرائيليه وبالتالي هناك ايضا اشتباكات
تسمع ما بين عناصر المقاومه الفلسطينيه
وقوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي المتمركزه في
منطقه جحر الديك في شرق مخيم البريج هذه
المنطقه تشهد اشتباكات ما بين يوم ويوم ما
بين عناصر المقاومه الفلسطينيه وقوات
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي المقاومه تعلن ما بين
فتره واخرى عن اطلاقها لقذائف ياسين
وتفجير عبوات وايضا تنفيذ حت عمليات
باتجاه قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي
المتمركزه في تلك المناطق لكن الاخطر من
كل ذلك ان وسط القطاع بات محاصرا في ظل
استمرار الجيش الاسرائيلي وقطعه لشارع
صلاح الدين وقطعه لشارع الرشيد من جهه
مدينه غزه وبالتالي يمنع الوصول الى مدينه
غزه من وسط القطاع وايضا قطع شارع صلاح
الدين من جهه خان يونس بمعنى ان وسط
القطاع بات محاصرا ولم يبقى له الا شارع
ضيق هو شارع الرشيد شارع البحر
الذي يصل ما بين وسط القطاع ومدينه
خانيونس ومدينه رفاح وبالتالي وصول
المساعدات بات صعبا في هذه الى هذه
المناطق حتى ان المواد التموينيه المواد
الاساسيه الوقود وكل ما يلزم لسكان القطاع
لا سما النازحون المتواجدون في وسط قطاع
غزه بات شحيحا للغايه المستشفيات ما
ينقصها من مساعدات من ادويه من مستلزمات
من حتى وقود لم يعد يصل بكميات وكافيه
لاستمرار عمل هذه المؤسسات بالتالي
الاوضاع تزداد صعوبه يوما بعد يوم على
الجانب الانساني وعلى الجانب الصحي كذلك
في ظل هذه الاوضاع الكارثيه وايضا في ظل
النقص الحاد في المستلزمات والادويه
والغذاء لا سما وان ما يصل من معبر رفح ما
زال هي كميات شحيحه للغايه وكما تصفها
السلطات والمؤسسات الحقوقيه والدوليه هي
نقطه في بحر احتياجات قطاع غزه وتتحدث
السلطات هنا بانه لم يعد لم يعد هناك ما
يكفي لحج السكان للبقاء على قيد الحياه
وايضا المياه الصالحه للشرب باتت شحيحه
للغايه كذلك شكرا لك هشام زقوت كنت معنا
من نادير البلح